today I'm going to be talking about a
very serious subject that you probably
already know about a few days ago a man
by the name of George Floyd was murdered
by a police officer while he was placed
under arrest the circumstances of his
arrest are irrelevant a man is dead and
this sort of situation
disproportionately affects a certain
percentage of the population
George Floyd was an african-american man
and there's a long storied history of
african-american men and women being
murdered or abused while being placed
under arrest
this is resulted in numerous
demonstrations protests and riots that
have occurred across the country and
centralized in Minneapolis and I think I
hate the term I think I do the last
thing I want to do is to try to inject
my opinion into a situation that neither
deserves it or needs it but I think that
this is a very human reaction to
systemic injustice and racism that has
been pervading our country for the past
50 100 200 years this is a problem that
is deeply rooted in our government and
in our communities and in these systems
that are supposed to help our fellow man
and it is a problem that needs to be
rooted out at every turn and it's always
been a big point of mine to try to use
my platform responsibly to use my
platform to steer people in the
direction that I feel is right in this
case there is very little gray area to
debate about a man is dead as a result
of police brutality and there was no
justice in his death and this happens
over and over and over again and it's
very easy to remove yourself from the
situation to think that it is so far
removed from your life that it will
never affect you but this affects all of
us this is something that is definitive
of who we are as a people who we will be
for the future generations I've always
said that I want to leave the world a
better place than I found it
when I'm gone I want the future
generations to be able to enjoy peace
and prosperity I want that but right now
we need to fight these and justices at
every turn because prejudice and
injustice and racism runs very deep and
its roots are very thick and if you
don't cut it out and if you don't stop
it at every turn it will always come
back and I think that the discontent is
a result of that anger of the
deep-seated anger of continually and
repeatedly being ignored Martin Luther
King once said that riots are the
language of the unheard which means that
when people are ignored for so long they
only have so many options to express
their rage and if there are problems
that continually crop up and lead to
these situations where justice is not
served then we need to change the
systems that allow that injustice to
happen in the first place and that is a
long process that needs continual
pressure and constant support and
constant vigilance I hope that we can
live in a world where racism and
Prejudice are in the past but the
realist in me knows that we need to
fight it at every turn and we need to
confront it and we need to challenge it
and we need to defeat it whenever it
rises up in the description I'm gonna
leave a link to a charity an
organization called the campaign zero
they are dedicated to ending police
violence in America or at the very least
ensure that justice is always served
when it is due I will be making a
contribution to this charity and I
encourage you to do the same or
contribute to many of the other causes
that people are linking on social media
on Twitter on various other sites or
other YouTube videos there are many ways
that you can help even at the most basic
of just letting people know that this is
not okay that we do not stand for this
making your voice heard you can make a
contribution to a charity or you can
spread the message about it and demand a
change be made from it
we are all in this together whether we
like it or not we're all part of the
same country we're all part of the same
world and we need to start looking out
for each other
black lives matter and right now we need
to fight this injustice